hello everybody um I would like to wish
everybody a Happy New Year and there's a
lot of things going on as many of you
know the patreon situation the patreon
debacle I guess we'll call it is
continuing on I am working very hard on
a solution for for this problem the
person who is programming my website
Mathew Raymer and his team is working to
find a way to get payment going and so
in the spirit of deep platforming and
censorship I thought that it would be a
good idea to look at a recent movie
called bird box a lot of you have
written me and asked me to interpret
this movie and so in watching it I had a
very strange vibe as many of you know
I've been working with Thomas ways on
Svan results.i I've been working very
hard to pronounce his name so I hope I
got it right so Thomas is is a one of
the partners on the storytellers channel
that is interpreting movies with a
symbolic flare with a lot of depth and
for a few months now we've been working
together we've done some partnerships
but he's also editing my movie videos
and I really respect his his perception
and it's used and so he wrote me a
little note and said did you you know
what did you think of Bird box and and I
noticed that we had some similar vision
and so I thought we'd do something new
this time and we just do it as a
conversation and interpret this movie
for you
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world and so so Thomas please
maybe you can start us off and give us a
few details maybe you can maybe do a
little bit of synopsis for people to
understand or a bit a bit of the premise
then we can go into to some of the
perception that we added this movie
right okay so I think the best way to
start this off is that we need to divide
the story and the film into the two
stories that are that are really in the
film sidharth's like the macro story
which is basically this this apocalypse
story of an invisible force or some sort
of spirit that you dropped somewhere in
Romania or Russia and it rapidly spreads
over the world and the thing it does is
that this is sort of like an evil evil
spirit or demon and it makes people go
crazy and if they look at it so it's
like invisible but if people look at it
and see it then they go crazy and they
commit suicide on the one hand so most
people commit suicide but on the other
hand there's a small group of people who
are evil or have some sort of twisted
mind who actually align themselves with
the demon or become possessed by it and
then sort of express the will of the
demon with their body and so did we have
this this protagonist I think her name
is Marjorie and and she's a woman and
she needs to basically survive and the
main arc if the story is her going down
this river to a sort of safe haven why
she needs to make camp so that's that's
the macro story but then there's a
second story going on which is on the
micro level which is basically which
focuses on Mallory or Mark Mallory and
it's basically about she's pregnant and
she doesn't want to be a mother or she
she's basically sending herself up to be
a terrible mother so her arc is
basically to to change or transform from
being a terrible mother into someone who
embraces motherhood and who transforms
from being a nihilist and we
sort of hopeful towards the answer that
those are the two stories are that are
sort of playing and intertwining
throughout so I think that that's sort
of like we need to keep those apart and
see how they they work together so yeah
in terms of the maze the basic arc of
the story like you said you know some of
the imagery is quite potent this notion
of this this river ride down a dangerous
river moving towards what's hopefully
for her a safe haven that also be part
of her arc as being an a mother who
doesn't want to be a mother and then
finally the whole movie ends you know
there's gonna be many spoilers so you
know hopefully you're not worried about
that
and towards I didn't hand where she
actually names her children and so this
whole time he's kind of showing her you
know coming into her role as a mother so
that's like arc itself it's quite is
quite good and it's quite yeah and it's
symbolically accurate for sure I think
we need to add as well as this movie is
based on a book with I think it has a
similar name I'm not sure but I hear
that the book is is quite different from
the story from from the movie but that
it does have this same sort of arc about
motherhood and I think that they in the
movie they add some things on it change
some things but I haven't read the book
so I can't really comment on it but
maybe for people who have at something
to say no and so the thing that is
strange I think that we both noticed
about the movie and the thing that is
also strange in in the political
situation in which we are is this idea
that if you look at certain thing like
if there's something there's this
horrible thing in the world and if you
look at it it's it's a horrible that it
will make you kill yourself or that it
will make you or it will let say make
you become evil and and want to align
yourself with this evil thing so the
during the whole movie people people are
hiding themselves in houses not wanting
to look outside they're wearing things
over their eyes so that they don't have
just the outside world and so their
basis so the whole premise of the story
is to create this space around you where
you actually don't have to or you don't
interact with the outside world which is
too dangerous and will cause you to
become crazy yeah
the interesting thing is that it's not
just like with your eyes and going
actually going outside and and you know
observing with your eyes but it's also
they they show that it's also dangerous
to look through cameras or like through
digital images and then there's this
very short segment where they're
watching TV the news and on the news to
say you can go on social media because
social media is dangerous as well so
it's all these sort of these levels of
perception everything is dangerous like
your eyes are basically useless so what
I found interesting about this as well
is that so you start off the story very
rapidly introduces this this apocalypse
and it quite literally flips the world
upside down in the sense that Malory is
sitting in a car of her sister and then
the car actually you know flips upside
down and then the world becomes inverted
writes to all the agents of order to put
you see the police and people who work
hospital and army like very quick very
quickly break down and then in their
place come like the criminals and crazy
people are like a very small contingent
of people who are somehow immune to this
new spirit or actually embrace this new
spirit and try to express what it wants
and what it's trying to do in the world
right and then I think what's what
you're saying is like this blindness
seems to be the main sort of visual
metaphor for this inversion whereas
normally you would say like no but their
eyes are our modes of observation how we
category categorize the world and so
it's like by shedding light on something
or by by looking at it we can integrate
it or dissolve it or we can make sense
out of it but now instead it's it's it's
turned upside down and and by looking at
it it actually kills us or we actually
help it spread its chaos or or or death
itself so that's what I found like very
like a strange notion was interesting
but the way it plays out in the story
towards its conclusion seems to be
aligned to what's happening right now
yeah exactly because I think the biggest
kind of reveal at the end which makes
you think that this is very disturbing
is that the the movie doesn't end with a
confrontation of the monster doesn't end
with the destruction of the
the monstrous for us it doesn't end with
with the end of this threat which you
would imagine you know a story like this
would would do but rather it ends in
this kind of this safe this could only
say a safe space where no more heaven
everything is kind of under like under
the tree let's say there's this kind of
this tree world and everybody yeah and
and the world is ruled by blind people
basically the blind are the ones who are
unit so they become kind of the the
kings of this this world where they
don't have to see or they can't see the
the the the outside world and so it's
it's a very strange ending for for a
movie to end that way yeah right it
seems to sort of progress in a state to
a state of not seeing or like not being
conscious and where it's like literally
it's the the the trees or the plants
discovered a whole like this sort of
bubble in which they let they now live
it's really strange but then but what I
found interesting is that quite a bit of
a couple of my friends actually compared
the movie to annihilation no for those
who haven't seen annihilations also a
Netflix movie starring Natalie Portman
and it's has a sort of a similar theme
in that it's also an apocalyptic event
and she's in ways also blind that she
has to go into this strange world where
things intertwine and nothing is sort of
as it seems and then but the conclusion
is quite different from what bird walks
is whereas I thought it would be going
in the same direction it doesn't
actually serve where bird walks where
there is at the end no confrontation
with Brad are sort of a isolation and
like sort of moving away from not
confronting the world at all because
it's too dangerous
and there it's like no there's this sort
of confrontation integration which is I
think the most powerful scene in the
movie and it moves back into the whole
world and the whole world is changed by
this sort of event of confronting this
this is forces external forces alien
force worse this is quite the opposite
and so and a funny thing is that I think
many people enjoyed bird locks but a lot
of my friends as well we're quite
underwhelmed by its ending they
something that didn't seem quite right
with it so I it only really resonates
with a certain
certain people on like the political
spectrum for who for whom it might
resonate with their views of the world
that's what I think personally yeah I
when I was watching it I remember cuz so
many people I think it's one of the
movies that the most people in a very
short amount of time said you should
watch this movie you should watch this
movie on it and as I was watching I
think about 30 40 minutes in I I wrote
on the social media this movie is
basically about Russian first like first
of all the the the source of the problem
originates in Russia or Romania in the
Middle East and Middle East in Eastern
Europe and and then it becomes this
thing that you that will destroy you
that will you know that will make you
become evil and the people that they
show I mean it's it's it's so hard it's
so frustrating you know you we want to
not have to see these things you know
you want to look at watch the movie and
you want to have to not to notice that
you know in a world that's very
multicultural you think okay that's fine
but then you don't want to have to
notice that every single bad person in
the movie every person that aligns with
this evil force is a stereotype of a
kind of Midwestern you know white guy or
Midwestern white person and so it's it's
it's very frustrating to have to kind of
to have to sit there and go oh come on
like why why is it that now you know
that the the hick in the river and then
the the the kind of gun-toting skinhead
Trump supporter you know the John
Malkovich character and then you know
it's like this constant every single
character that gets infected by the
thing and doesn't kill himself is yeah
right well yeah that's like you can not
see for I think like sometimes people
see it through their own ideological
lens and like they you know they see
racism everywhere or like some sort of
intent but here it is very clear that
it's been that's been done intentionally
because you had literally half a John
Malkovich character say like a very
strange line that's completely out of
place and movie system
we make let's make the end of the world
great again and then there's like a two
or three second azar days from zoom in
and everyone's facing us with like
cringing and it's like it's it's the
flow out of the movie completely and
it's completely out of place but I mean
it's you can see here that it's very
intentional by people who made the film
that they very intentionally make
thought about this and they placed in a
movie and even you know John Malkovich
his character he doesn't actually en
turn into sort of one of these people
who becomes possessed by the spirit but
he still is portrayed as a sort of an
antagonist in his own right just not
like the main antagonists like he's he's
definitely a forced conflict within this
sort of safe bubble that that they
existed in the first half of the film
and all the other sort of white male
characters in the film are portrayed and
they sort of similar negative lights so
you have there's one sort of minor
character who I think is like a drug
addict and he's like sort of criminal
Dennison type character we don't really
know much about we just and easy build a
car he steals the key steals a car that
guy yeah but I thought what I noticed
about him was that he runs away with the
girl who is going to be a cop who was
like in the Academy to become a cop and
she the first interaction that or the
first time you see him actually we see
him take drugs or medicine or some kind
and and the woman says you know I'm a
cop right and so then their relationship
starts to develop from there but it's
basically about him possessing her into
leaving the house you can see like a
couple of times I show up it's like sort
of he actually tells her right in the
beginning that they should leave the
place when one of the characters I think
commits suicide and then he's like we
should leave and so we sort of
foreshadows what's going to happen but
it's it's the way it's done it seems
like he is sort of a microcosm for that
spirit that's out there and sort of
possessing people and you see that
happen within their relationship it's a
bit of I don't know if it's if it's
right but it seems to me that that
that's what intent was but maybe I'm
Robert at least it seems to align was a
broader narrative at the very least he's
shown in a very negative light yeah all
the other yeah and
there's the John Malkovich character
there's the hick in the river which is
the most kind of the most obvious you
know he's he looks like he's right out
of deliverance and then there yeah
there's the guy who comes in and at
first you think he's fine and then
finally you realize that he's like a
servant of this evil force and then he
basically causes the whole place to to
break down because he starts opening the
windows and starts showing people you
know this this beautiful evil thing and
so and so yeah so it's it's it's kind of
and I think that it's one of those
things where while you're watching it
you're like oh come on like why why are
you forcing me to notice this I wish I
didn't have to watch a movie and think
about these things but yes that's what's
that's what's that's what seems to have
been the message of the or the use of
symbolism in the movie seems to be way
more propagandistic than than anything
else in the case of this story yeah I
agree yeah definitely agree it's yeah
but even without taking that into
account just the story itself and and
the story of the motherhood and how she
transforms and so you like someone who
doesn't want to have a kid and you've
sort of hates kids
it's you someone who who embraces
motherhood it's still the conclusion
that that doesn't make any sense to me
because so in the end she's like okay I
need to be less protective and sort of
embrace having kids and she gives him
their names and their identities but
then it's still it's not like she you
know lets them confront the outside
world it's like no they can they can
play around but as long as it is in this
enclosed space where it's like it's just
like a artificial space and they don't
have to confront that really anything so
nothing really changes it's like it's
we're still at the start of the movie
where she's sort of isolated in her own
space and then we're in the same
position really so I don't that doesn't
make much sense I know if I'm missing
peas and puzzle there but it's just a
very strange yeah it doesn't seem for
sure it doesn't seem like there's much
of a future there at least not like yeah
it seems like there's it doesn't end
with much it seems to want to end with
hope for the future because it shows us
these birds that go up you know but then
they go up and they hit you know this
wall of trees like that side that
scene where she lets the birds go you
think like obviously I know what that is
like you've seen this yet he's that kind
of scene in all kinds of stories but
then it's like they go up and then
there's this tree there under the canopy
of the forest you know living under
under the canopy so it's a it's a mean
in a certain way I guess I guess then
the whole theme of the whole movie ends
up being about this kind of this kind of
covering or this protecting you know and
so the mother let's say the the positive
and a negative aspect of the of the
mother ends up coming out in the movie
where you know it's like the mother that
covers but then you know covers to her
to really protects you from the evil
outside world but then there isn't this
trend there isn't a transcendence of
that of that moment where it's just
about protecting people from the outside
yeah I thought about it a little bit
more so so besides that she that Mallory
does not want to have kids she also
seems to be quite nihilistic and she
becomes like really nihilistic once you
know apocalypse happens so it's and and
towards the end when she when they're
almost at this age bit safe-haven she
falls down and then the kids run away
and she's like I know I I need to give
them hope he needs to give him the sort
of a story that her boyfriend Tom tried
to tell them he's like the story of the
tree and like this this garden said that
he's fundin like that they can climb up
the tree end day and they see like a
family or something I don't know it's
it's it's a story of like a hope and she
doesn't want to give it to him because
she she thinks that there isn't hope so
perhaps it is more it resonates to
degree that some people or have seen
today society is like that we're in a
position where there is very little hope
and it is so so nihilistic but she the
only thing that she can do is not be as
not let them grow up in in a similar
manner and that they become nihilistic
as well that they at least need to have
some hope even though that maybe the
world will never be okay again that they
get this dream even though it might not
be a real dream that that there is still
hope for a better world I don't know it
I'm trying to figure out why it didn't
have more
and it didn't make sense like I felt
like it was sort of setting it up for
the sort of confrontation with with the
spirit but it just doesn't happen in
they destroy seclude themselves and then
they're happy but it's kind of weird
because because you would you would
expect like you would have movies like
this that could end badly like it could
have ended in an on an ominous tone
where for example it ends where you know
the window is all open and everybody
kind of looks up and then the movie ends
that way like you could have had a dark
ending for the movie but the movie wants
to end with a hopeful tone but yeah
that's the problem it's like it's
supposed to be a happy ending but it's a
very disturbing happy ending because
it's basically just living in a bubble
is basically just living in a safe space
and and and and not being able to
confront this outside this outer evil
thing that's that's there so it's that's
a very strange thing yeah yeah I don't
it's it's it's and also it seems to like
the whole thing about them not being
able to look or not being allowed to to
look at this thing it's like it seems to
be representative of of this idea or
this notion in the real world where it's
where ideas or like deviant ideas or
things that are dangerous like things
that aren't accept that can be dangerous
and can like brainwash you or presenters
a few so that's why I think the whole
thing about that social media is unsafe
as well like people who who are
susceptible to this like which seems to
be a lot of people will eventually die
from it or like it will be it will be
negative I have some negative
consequence or or maybe they'll become
depressed or like and don't want to
commit suicide because of how terrible
it is but then only the people who are
already sort of aligned with that that
strain of thought can look at it and be
like oh does this is amazing and they
even they have like I felt like they had
more sort of Trump lines in it because
there's like a point when at the very
end when this this group of thugs
finally find Mallory and our boyfriend
and and they're trying to make her Tom
look at thing and they're like and
they're saying oh it's it's a beautiful
thing and that's also something that
Trump says a lot so I don't know if that
one was
maybe I'm yeah so anyways it seems to be
they sure they had for sure they had
they had those intentions that's for
sure I yeah the whole time I kept
thinking that in a way this movie is if
this movie was the matrix it's basically
taking the blue pill that's what it is
because in the matrix it's exactly that
point where it's like it's he's saying
you know you if you take this yeah it's
gonna be dangerous for you and and when
he takes the the pill then you see him
he almost goes crazy like this he's
gonna lose it he's gonna lose it he's
gonna go crazy but then he's able to
master the difficult truth of the
difficult reality whereas in this movie
it's like it really is a praise of the
blue pills like stay inside this this
box they inside this box and and you'll
be fine you know don't confront the
difficult things they'll confront the
difficult situations
okay yeah so if you ever watch The
Matrix and you want to explore what the
blue pill is then just stop watching the
matrix in but for sure I mean the whole
this whole culture that we have right
now be platforming everything that it's
been happening on patreon on YouTube on
Twitter there there has been massive
deep platforming some of the people we
don't hear about because they're not so
famous they don't have a voice but there
has been a lot more Dee platforming than
what people think and so this this idea
and that's why I kept bringing it back
to this notion of the Russian BOTS this
idea that somehow because some people
you know saw Russian propaganda that
that's why you know Donald Trump won the
election or the idea that if you're that
you're exposed to certain ideas that
they'll infect you so much that that
you'll become an evil you know an evil
person I think that that's something
that underlies the whole philosophy of
the platforming whether it's in the
universities whether it's on social
media now and and so it's a it just fits
very nicely into that whole narrative
and no wonder that it's received so much
praise from you know
stuff Hollywood I just saw I just saw a
lot of praise from from certain circles
let's say oh my god yeah it's it was I
mean it was entertaining to watch but it
was it was just very it was serious it
was entertaining for the wrong reasons
at least for me because it was so so
strange
that's watch but yeah maybe so
here's a question so the film obviously
is called bird box and birds play quite
a significant role in it and and they're
sort of you know as they tell when the
spirit is near but like I I wasn't quite
sure how to how to look at the birds and
what they sort of represent in in in the
film like obviously the birds it seems
logical to me that they are more
spiritually attuned to to to be like
feeling when the spirit is around as
they're more like a spiritual yeah
animal in the symbolic sense but besides
that it also more in the human scale it
seems to be that they represent this
sort of like whistleblowing or or like
the people who tweet when there's
someone or something around hilarious
yeah so like that's the first thing
that's that I thought about but then I
was like nah well that makes more sense
just in small except that they are more
spiritually it soon and obviously they
can use the mind so that that connection
seems seems logical but yeah still like
they named the whole thing bird box and
it's about like I guess it's coming out
if you're out of this sort of shell but
it's in just another shell like it
doesn't make sense to me at all that the
whole notion of birds so yeah I think
you're right I think that the whole
movie is about birds in a box and that's
what it is that's the whole premise of
the story and it ends it ends it make
what makes us want to believe that the
birds leave the box at the end but they
don't they're still in the box
and so I basically what the whole story
is about is is really about is about you
know and and there's something not
totally false about it in the sense that
this sense of this something spiritual
which is precious and needs to be
protected you know it needs to be held
like we have these stories about your
this image of the pearl
in a in a in a shell you know we have
these different images of something
which is precious and needs to be
protected that's not it's not a totally
wrong story but you know there's also
the this story like Christ would also
there'll be balance of the story of the
talents for example where Christ the
story of someone who gives his servants
talents of gold and you know and and he
expects them not to bury that it aground
in and protect it at all cost but rather
to to break take them out in the world
and to make them be fruitful and so in
that sense the story just shows one side
of the whole dilemma which is that it is
true that's something that's precious
something that's meaningful our
identities all this thing they need to
be protected but not only protected they
also need to be need to be able to rise
up and to face you know whatever
challenges them and whatever is is
facing them so so I think that for sure
this movie veers almost completely on
one side yeah yeah alright guys so I
think you know I this was a lot of fun
for me like I I don't know maybe Thomas
and I will do this again I really think
he's got a good symbolic intuition and
it's rare that I find people that have
that and so look forward to more videos
obviously edited by Thomas but but maybe
we'll have them back on the channel to
to to have these kinds of discussions
again and so I will wish you guys all
once again a Happy New Year and
hopefully we'll have more pleasant
things to talk about talk about during
the year besides bird box so comments I
want to say our last word well thank you
for for having me on I enjoyed ranting
about this movie a lot I hope and as you
said I hope we can talk about more
positive things as well because I think
there's a lot of deconstructing and
people ranting on YouTube already so but
I know usually we do things about movies
that we actually like so I think maybe
next time we can do that so alright
alright guys we'll see you later
you